Princeton is absolutely a leader
around diversity and inclusion.
Diversity is so important
because we need so many more
diverse students, faculty, and
staff here
that will not only enhance
Princeton,
but help Princeton to
continue to grow.
We have a president
who "gets it",
we have senior leaders
who "get it"
they understand that
this is a priority
and there's been an incredible
investment all across campus
towards this effort
because we know the importance
of all members of our community
from students, to faculty,
to staff,
to our alumni and visitors even
to feel that they are a part of
a community that is caring,
that is inclusive, where they
can be valued contributors
to the overall mission
of excellence.
Princeton is so amazing at this
moment because we are at a time
of a complete culture shift, and
faculty, staff, and students
have an opportunity  to be
a part of that change, a part
of that growth, in a direction
that is very much inclusive
of all communities of
all people.
Given the 2013 trustee report on
supporting diversity and
other initiatives that went
along with that, that was
very attractive to me
when I was looking at
employment potentially
at Princeton.
The investments are visible
on campus in terms of
staffing resources, deans for
diversity in many offices,
centers that have been
developed and grown.
It's a continuous effort.
There are about 7,000 students
on campus if you include
undergrad and graduate students,
and we have about
65 professionals whose full time
job is to support
diversity and inclusion
on campus.
It's not just a workplace,
it's a community.
The people who work at
the institution really
care about one another.
Staff, faculty, the students,
they really want to make
this place something that
is remarkable and unique
in its community. The way that
it helps individuals
form relationships
with one another.
I just think it's a
vibrant place to work.
It's a place that's committed
to excellence. It's committed to
honoring people, and
bringing them forward
helping them to grow.
Princeton currently has ten
employee resource groups
that support a wide array of
different communities on campus.
We do a lot of consultation
around a whole host of
diversity and inclusion matters,
and support staff in thinking
about how to make Princeton
a more equitable place to be,
and a more diverse place,
really an inclusive place
for all staff.
Princeton has a lot of
services and centers.
So we also have the
Women's Center, the LGBT Center,
Davis International Center, the
Center for Jewish Life, the
Office of Disability services,
As well as
the Office of Religious Life,
and the Carl Fields center.
We're working in populations
of students that are more
diverse than we've ever
seen in our history.
And we need to make sure that
those students that come
from diverse backgrounds
are well represented.
Institutions are in such a rush
to check off what we're
trying to accomplish, and in
that process really forget
the real fundamental reason why
the communities exist, and
they're built and they
exist on trust.
Tolerance is not enough to
create community.
Respect, as wonderful as
that is, is not enough.
Honoring and celebrating,
including all, not maintaining
the majority and making a little
bit of space to accommodate
those that are different, but
actually having a space where
everyone has an equal stake in
what it means to be
a Princetonian.
It's important to have dialog
and discussion here on campus,
especially done in
an environment that is
facilitated by peers.
It's important to provide that
opportunity for students to
be able to explore, to be
able to challenge themselves,
and further grow into who they
are and really think about
their identity and not only of
themselves but also how
they influence community.
Every single person is
different, and disability
is just another
type of difference.
The main purpose for the
Office of Disability Services
is to be a place for students
who have disabilities and
to talk with us about
accommodations that may be
helpful to them in a classroom
or in navigating campus.
It really warms my heart when
I can see a student who has
overcome barriers and has then
been able to take advantage
of the academic experiences
here that will enable them
to make a difference
in this world.
Princeton University is probably
one of the most pluralistic
campuses in America when
it comes to religious life.
It offers opportunities for
worship, offers opportunities
for learning about one's faith
or another person's faith.
There is not only a full time
Muslim Chaplin and there is
also a full time Hindu Chaplin,
and we have many different
Christian denominations, we have
different sects within
Judaism represented. You can ask
the tough questions and
no one will shun you for it.
It aspires to be a place
where everyone can find
a spiritual home.
I believe that diversity and
inclusion and concepts around
social justice are not addition,
it's not an add on
and it's not something extra,
it's just who we are
and who we want our
students to be, and what
we want them to know as we
prepare to create leaders
for a global society.
I really admire that Princeton
can acknowledge its shortcomings
as well as celebrate
its accomplishments.
And when we acknowledge that we
have work to do, we act.
And we lead in many of
these areas in improving
the experiences that our
students have, that our staff
and faculty have.
You know it's not only about
making sure that our
institution is always keeping in
mind what an ethical utopian
vision of itself would look
like, but also that we're
creating the kinds of people and
future leaders that can go out
in the world and make that
change more broadly.
People have
good intentions here.
They care about each other.
You feel that when
you're on campus.
We all are responsible for the
well-being of each other, and
if we live that we all
raise each other up.
We have a responsible to grow,
to learn from the lessons
of the past
and to be committed to that
vibrant present and
translate it into
a better future,
into a better Princeton,
a brighter Princeton.